okay tons of emails and comments
flooding in about Donald Trump adviser
Stephen Miller's appearance yesterday on
Jake Tapper Sunday morning program the
comments were mostly one he didn't make
any sense in what he was saying and
number two he didn't make any sense in
how he was saying it weirdly slurring
his speech and twitching in kind of a
weird way I actually there was actually
a reddit post about this where a user
said in the Jake Tapper interview this
morning every minute or so yeah this odd
twitch on I think his right side I'm
curious if he's okay or maybe he has a
coke problem I'm going to play some
pieces of this interview for you the
slurring is I don't know about the drug
usage stuff the slurring is more of a
downer thing not upper but he does have
a weird twitch but I think he's always
had that it might be sort of like
anxiety being on camera or something I
did repeat an anecdote at one point
though that's the only reason I'm about
that sort of thing he repeated it at
least one time yeah that was weird it's
an absolutely ridiculous interview let's
start playing a little bit of it here if
you're watching check out the weird
movements if you're listening you might
hear the weird speech pattern a
phenomenon was happening that you didn't
see a phenomenon was happening that the
rest of the political class didn't see
of all these so-called political
geniuses in Washington whether it be at
the big lobbying firms or the only
genius in the last week is the president
but you because happens to be a true
statement okay it's self-made
billionaire who revolutionize reality TV
and who's yours the Cory's Brock is
happy that you said that but Jake might
be no no you might be condescending and
it's been kind of sending I'm he's been
in you can be conscious and that was a
snide remark you sure he's watching he's
happy let me tell you something why is
there a network you can look you can be
as condescending as you want it's part
of your mo a lot of the entire thing was
like this basically Steven Miller not
allowing Jake Tapper to even get a
question out and just criticizing Jake
Tapper's demeanor during the interview
let's watch just another example of this
interview and it just gets worse and
worse but listen the you can have 24/7
I have no idea why your exam you want
man it's UPN Jake you can have eight how
many voices president's travel ban would
be about to you know I'm so glad you
brought that up that's one of the same a
news I even in the
Stephen I would happen to know better
than you would Jake about how the travel
ban was written let me bid and see
Benton and push the travel would let me
see better without it right if you let
me ask you know because you have written
24 hours of negative antitrump
hysterical coverage on this network that
led in recent weeks as some
spectacularly embarrassing false report
I think the wrong word Network now can
assert a nose the viewers are entitled I
have my three months of the truth why
don't you just give me three minutes to
tell you the truth about Donald Trump
that I know yeah the real Donald Trump
that Stephen Miller knows my guess is
like the Donald Trump that nearly 200
people described in Michael Wolf's book
fire and fury but somehow I don't think
that's the real Donald Trump that
Stephen Miller wanted to talk about
anyway this next part is great Jake
Tapper tries to use the voice that a
preschool teacher uses when a
four-year-old is a little rambunctious
and once this sit still Jake Tapper
actually uses that voice on Stephen
Miller and the craziest part is it
almost kind of works because I want to
do that so down settle down calm down
Jake I have a question for you about
issues Steven Bannon who the president
says had nothing to do with this
presidency he was part of the
president's travel ban he was part of
pulling out of the Paris climate deal he
was part of withdrawing from the TPP
he's part of border security he's part
of being tough on in every way to go no
I don't want to go through but my point
is is it really the position of the
Trump White House that Steve Bannon had
nothing to do with the presidency or can
you acknowledge the reality that he was
a key player I think that what the point
is is that his role has been greatly
exaggerated right as the president
hasn't gotten the do that he deserves
for the movement that he put together to
tap into the kinds of people whose life
concerns don't get a lot of attention on
CNN that is the way you act if you are
scared s Ellis about what Trump is gonna
do if you don't do his bidding the right
way and we saw what happened to Sean
Spicer when he didn't do Trump's bidding
the right way Jake Tapper did actually
try to get to some real questions here's
one about the Russia contacts between
Trump personally and Russians not
surprisingly no answer from Stephen
Miller and he said that quote the chance
that Don jr. did not walk these gem o's
up to his father's office on the 26th
floor
is zero did President Trump meet with
any of the so-called GMOs who were in
that Trump Tower meeting Steve band's
eloquence in that description
notwithstanding it's tragic and
unfortunate that Steve would make these
grotesque comments so out of touch with
reality and obviously so vindictive and
the whole White House just disappear
into in because it just goes on like
that for 90 seconds and I don't want to
subject people to it and Jake Tapper
does try once more to get an answer from
him on that question and still doesn't
so you were at the campaign during that
Trump Tower meeting I believe right in
the summer of 2016 just to answer the
question because you were there and
Steve Bannon was not did any of those
people from that meeting meet with
President Trump as Bannon says the
chance that he didn't to Don jr. didn't
walk these GMOs up to his father's
office on the 26 for 0 can you just
settle that for us did President Trump
meet with any of the people I have no
knowledge of anything to do with that
meeting okay but what I can tell you
unequivocally is that the allegations
and insinuations in this book which are
which are a pure work of fiction right
he has no knowledge one way or the other
but he knows that what Michael Wolfe
said about the meeting is a lie how does
that possible that part was weird
visually it's very strange it's very
very strange and eventually Jake Tapper
had to cut him off because Miller just
wouldn't stop filibustering and kick
them off the show those voices those
experiences don't get covered on this
network that's why the I mean it to
prove the point
I was I was booked to talk about the
very issues I'm just describing you're
not even asking about him because
they're not interesting facts to you
that's not true I have a plenty of
questions in there Grayson you have the
filibuster by talking about your flight
no question because you don't know
nobody kind of sent I'm Jay Jay even
Jake reason in the White House the
reason why the president reason why I
want to talk about the president's
experiences what I've seen with him
traveling to meet dozens of foreign
leaders with his incredible work okay
you know using the questions yeah I
understand you have 24 hours a day of
ant Steven Tyrael you're not gonna give
three minutes for the American people
gather the really curios one viewer that
you care about right now and you're
being obsequious never being a fan
please him okay wasted enough of my
viewers in a major reversal that most
like Miller didn't understand this was a
question and answer format where Jake
Tapper asked questions and he answers
them a Miller ended up being escorted
off the set this this was like two
sources close to the situation said that
after the taping was done Miller was
asked to leave several times and he
wouldn't leave and eventually security
was called
and he was escorted out sometimes I
wonder what the future holds for people
like Stephen Miller once Trump is gone
well yeah and Donald Trump obviously
watched this too obviously he tweeted
right away yeah yeah saying that Stephen
Miller destroyed Jake Tapper on CNN so
this audience of one thing held up it
was absolutely true and not exactly the
way I saw it
we'll take a break back with Bill share
after this the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad